how good a workout is spinning poi well
to be honest with you I don't really
know I've long advocated for POI
spinning and flow Arts as a fitness
activity but I've never really sat down
and figured out exactly like you know
what kind of a workout it is and the
specific benefits of it but I'm going to
try and get an answer to that question
today Drex here from drexfactor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today
we're talking about benefits to both but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
all right so it is a lovely day here in
Washington DC we are up in the 70s
I have a project that I have been
working on for the past few months a bit
of choreography that I now have a studio
booked and a videographer booked so I'm
going to get to put that down on video
for The Prestige of forever
but I also need to refine some aspects
of the choreography
and I figured that since I have some
pretty intense tasks to do it's not a
bad opportunity to try and test out some
of the fitness related parts of poi
spinning so I have this Garmin that my
brother got me for Christmas a couple
years ago which I feel really bad about
the fact that I never use it or wear it
just because like I don't know bulky
things on my wrist it's kind of not my
deal not my style but it is quite useful
for being able to keep track of workout
keeping track of my heart rate
respiration and of course calories
burned in the course of doing an hour's
worth of flow so in order to test this
out I am going to spend the next hour
flowing in various different ways I'm
going to break my workout into three
parts the first one I'm going to be
trying to get down a trick that I've
been struggling with the second part I'm
going to be doing just free unstructured
flow and the third one is I'm going to
be working specifically on the
choreography in this piece and I'm going
to stop after each section to kind of
check in and see what my Peak heart rate
was during each of them as well as
you know how many calories burned Etc so
hopefully by the end of my practice
session today we will have some answers
at the very least I'm going to wind up
being a lot sweatier so you can check my
super duper Advanced system here for uh
so for setting up my iPad for recording
yeah we uh we always go top of the line
here at drexfactor poi all right so
there wasn't really a good comparison in
here to uh uh to what flow is so I
selected yoga so let's see how this goes
now let's uh
let's go ahead and get started on
learning uh working on a trick that I've
been struggling with
20 minutes
Starts Now
[Music]
oh
all right so the trick I'm actually
working on is this basically I'm trying
to take Gunslingers in Split Time same
direction in wall plane here go back and
forth between one being high one being
low
switching off with spiral wraps yeah now
as you can see I am not quite there I
still have a lot of work to do on this
one
um so the two things that I'm working on
today to lead up to it number one are
just working on doing back-to-back
spiral wraps in Split Time same
direction here on wall plane which is a
whole task in and of itself and also I'm
working on getting the changes in uh
changes in levels Happening by drilling
it in together opposite so that I can
hopefully bring together all those
pieces later on I don't think that's
going to happen today but might surprise
me in the meantime however I'm about 10
minutes into doing this and my heart
rate is hovering around 120 which is a
good sign especially given that I'm
being a little Tech Tree here
so let's see how the rest of the section
of the workout goes then shall we
[Music]
foreign
well I wound up using the entire 20
minutes doing the same drill over and
over again I was trying for 20 reps of
those split same spiral wraps and I just
never got there and I just uh kind of
hyper focused on it and didn't get onto
the other exercise as I was doing it I
definitely noticed that my heart rate
was peaking at around 125 or so as for
calories burned at this point
okay this might be harder ironically
enough since I set the thing that I was
doing as yoga
I think that so it's got a little uh
monitor on here that says stress
um and I think that it it blanked out
for a little while there so I think that
I might have
blown the curve on stress as I was
working on that uh
on on that trick there ah okay so it
looks like I burned 212 calories while I
was doing that okay let's see if cardio
is a better fit for uh doing some flow
uh so basically I'm just gonna flow for
the next 20 minutes
um and see how that works out for me uh
I don't really have any kind of
structure to this I'm just gonna see
what happens as I'm spinning maybe I'll
find something I like maybe I don't but
either which way I think I will at least
uh get some movement in me
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so we are a little over 10 minutes into
this section of the workout uh glanced
at my heart rate and it's been peaking
around 1 30 which is awesome calories
were already past 100 calories for this
10 minutes of flow Burns a hundred
calories that's not bad
cool let me uh let me keep going I'm
definitely sweating to the oldies here
[Music]
foreign
so
got 20 minutes of uh just free flow in
there and uh came up just shy at 200
calories I came to 197.
my heart rate peaked I want to say it
like around 1 30 in there I will have to
double check that when I wrap all this
up yeah for right now
we're 40 minutes in and we've burned
over 400 calories so uh that's uh that's
not bad it's not bad at all all right so
for this next section here I am
basically going to perform bitter choreo
record on the iPad and then come back
and check it and see what needs to be
changed before I run the whole thing
again
two times
[Music]
all right I think that was what I wanted
let's let's check the playback
[Music]
[Applause]
uh you know how there's a thing you see
in your head
and sometimes
thing just like doesn't manifest the way
you want it to
it's kind of where I'm at with this
right now so
um I'm just gonna run the piece top to
bottom here see what it looks like see
if there's anything I want to correct
and then run it maybe a couple more
times
we are at this point
um probably 10 or 15 minutes into this
last section and I have burned maybe a
hundred and ten 120 calories so uh
yeah this is uh definitely the least
intensive part thus far but I have a
feeling that's about to change
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
baby
[Music]
so those last two runs together burned
about 100 calories just in and of
themselves and that was uh
that was six minutes so I think we have
found a winner in terms of uh the most
arduous physical exercise here
so
I think I'm going to do just one more
run of this today
um
and then I think it is time to wind
things down and pack it in a wee bit
Yeah Yeah
[Music]
foreign
oh my goodness
um yeah so all told
um the past hour I burned according to
the Garmin here uh I burned a grand
total of uh 718 calories
which puts POI spinning and flow arts on
par with things like swimming and biking
and running in terms of Fitness which is
kind of cool that's great to hear
um I am I'm definitely exhausted at this
point as you can see I am just dripping
with sweats uh running this piece those
last three times took a lot out of me so
I think it is time for me to go inside
and replace some of these calories that
I've burned here thanks so much for
going on this journey with me
um
and uh yeah I hope that you're able to
find that POI spinning in flow Arts meet
your Fitness needs I'm curious have any
of you all monitored uh how many
calories you burn and what your heart
rate is oh yeah my heart rate topped out
at like 150 or 160 in there
um so yeah let me know down in the
comments uh what have been your Fitness
experiences with POI and flow Arts if
you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like share comment
and subscribe to help keep the
conversation going and to help other
people find my channel
foreign
this video would not be possible if not
for the kind support of all these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible I'm
getting so much sweat in my eyes right
now and it's staying so bad hang on uh
anyway if you are not currently a
supporter
well you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
directs Factor POI and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you and if you'd
like to check out some of the other
videos that I have done on POI and flow
arts and physical fitness I'm going to
go ahead and leave a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here
because it's popular amongst viewers of
my channel so maybe give that a look as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today I hope
you get in your exercise there and I'll
see you in the new video real soon
peace